Eric Moss here with another new
rockstars hot take the trailer for
Ant-Man the was guanamania includes this
angry looking shot of Kang Mega Manning
the crap out of the quantum realm but
this IMAX version of this trailer
thankfully shows this in 4k which allows
us to see a lot more detail like how
Kang's armor on his shoulders and arms
in this moment shifts upward on its own
looking a lot like Tony Stark's nanotech
armor from The Mark 50 onward we know he
remains at the trophy of the Iron Man
helmet and Loki concept art so did this
Kang steal Tech and weaponry from
Avengers that he killed in the past and
he's just angry to have to use an attack
that shows the Machinery of his magic in
this moment and have to reveal the
murderer behind the curtain